Michael what's wrong
okay wait wait wait
Michael do you need me to call an
ambulance
okay wait a second I thought you said
that you were hurt
no
hey whoa Michael oh God it's okay it's
Jim just say again really loudly uh what
happened okay
[Music]
I now need someone to come and bring me
into work you burned your foot on a
Foreman Grill I enjoy having breakfast
in bed I like waking up to the smell of
bacon sue me and since I don't have a
butler I have to do it myself so most
nights before I go to bed I will lay six
strips of bacon out on my George Foreman
Grill then I go to sleep when I wake up
I plug in the grill I go back to sleep
again then I wake up to the smell of
crackling bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's a
perfect way to start the day
today I got up I stepped onto the grill
and I clamped down on my foot that's it
I don't see what's so hard to believe
about that
sorry I'm ready
I'll go
oh
come on bear man
have you ever seen him do that
I'm sorry
I had no idea no it's okay
okay oh my God
oh my God no no no
ah
okay this is it what what is this one go
go oh my God
[Music]
in the end the greatest snowball isn't a
snowball at all
it's fear
Merry Christmas
Staying Alive you were in the parking
lot earlier that's how I know you
uh uh uh staying alive staying alive
staying alive
oh you can't tell by the way how I use
my walk I'm a woman's man no time to
talk what is it loud women more being
kicked around since I was born when it's
all right it's okay you can't look the
other way
[Music]
Staying Alive yeah okay you didn't
maintain 100 beats per minute and the
ambulance didn't arrive because nobody
called 9-1-1 so you lost them okay he's
dead anyone know what we do next anybody
Rose I have no idea anyone else we bury
him wrong and check for an organ donor
card if he has one we only have minutes
to harvest he has no wallet I check he
is an organ donor he is yeah give me
some ice in a styrofoam bucket here we
go
all right we searched for the organs
where's the heart
the Press hard I'm not feeling well I
need to sit on them
are you okay
oh my God oh my God
at least once a year I like to bring in
some of my Kevin's famous chili the
trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot that I'm serious about
this stuff
I'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes I toast my own
ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from Malone's
for Generations
it's probably the thing I do best
this is going to be a very good year
very good
Jan is at home Jim is back
my protege Ryan is a corporate
good stuff
um Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales
team I feel very blessed
hey Toby
hey
it's you hey so now that we are dating
uh we just want to know if we had to
sign one of those who are dating things
for the company
oh well you know those are only for
you know relationships
so if it's just a casual thing there's
no need really oh well I don't want to
speak for Tim but it's like pretty
official
uh-huh
sorry so do we need to sign one or
let's just wait and see what happens
yeah
what
let's just wait
oh okay okay great
White
what everybody was scared out of there
everyone okay uh I have an announcement
apparently in business school they don't
teach you how to operate a toaster oven
because some smart sexy temp left his
cheese pita an oven instead of timing it
for the toaster thing wow
well I guess they don't teach how to
operate a toaster oven in business
that's exactly what I said hey did you
miss that date there Ryan reaction oven
101. you failed so sorry
hey I know what will impress everybody
I'll start a fire
oh man bad idea bad idea jeans I have
its song attention everyone that I want
to sing that I wrote especially for this
occasion when I was up there among the
flames
ready
Ryan started
the burnings it's a world for turning
Ryan started the fire it was always
foreign
I'm so so sorry for the temperature in
here
the um sliding glass door shattered
it's actually a really cute story do you
want to tell it babe or should I tell it
I don't like that story babe come on
it's a cute story Michael ran through
the sliding glass door because he
thought he heard the ice cream truck
stop it but I mean I like ice cream okay
sue me oh no don't I shouldn't say that
jokingly because she will sue me she
loves to sue she loves lawsuits you know
honey that door was extremely clean and
it looked invisible you are so right you
are so right because before I lived here
the glass was always covered
[Music]
you are she is she is the devil I'm in
hell
I'm burning
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
as soon as I heard that rapper you
really have to say oh yeah every time
you eat a candy bar I can't help it
Oscar it's just really good
oh yeah my hands are tight all right not
bad at all I think we can beat 20
minutes though so let's try again get it
all out now if you have to it was a
raccoon eating a hamburger like a person
you need to stop banging your pen on
your desk or it's gonna drive me insane
okay does anyone have a first aid kit
check out this song I wrote I'm gonna
love you downstairs tonight
all right here we go everybody get ready
in three two good luck one all right